[Music]
uh this next question says can you help
me get a better answer from pastor skeet
i do not seem to understand when the
lesson talks about resting in peace
yet the dead know
nothing from the biblical standpoint all
the dead are the same knowing nothing so
every dead person is in the same state i
guess the person is saying how do we
reconcile resting the dead resting in
peace and not knowing anything
well rest is no different from sleep the
bible says death is asleep the bible
uses sleep to describe death
when the disciples told jesus and
lazarus was sick jesus said lazarus
sleepeth that's what jesus said a
sleeping person is a resting person now
we know the dead know nothing but it
does not change the fact the bible
describes death as a sleep so we can
understand and so when people say rest
in peace they're not saying the person
is alive
they're simply saying we hope you've
passed away in jesus so when he comes
you take you home that's all the person
is saying rest in peace is the
expression it is not a doctrinal
declaration it's an expression residence
but the bible says death is asleep from
which god will wake the righteous of the
wicked the righteous to go home with him
the wicked to receive the final
destruction but yes the dead know
nothing we know that a sleeping person
knows nothing either
a drunk person knows nothing either by
the way
a lot of people have been abused in a
state of drunkenness and realize it only
when they became sober so a lot of
conditions in which we know nothing when
you sleep when you get drunk we know
nothing
but
the expression rest in peace is merely a
traditional saying which means i hope
you lie in christ and may he take his
kingdom when he comes
amen amen
you